he wants to see a peaceful negotiated
outcome if that were possible but
vladimir putin is plainly determined to
double down on his path of violence and
aggression
absolutely brutal a way he's treating
the ukrainian people
we've got to step up we've got to
increase our
support and we've got to tighten the
economic vice around putin sanctioning
more people today as we are sanctioning
the wagner group looking at what we can
do to
stop putin using his gold reserves but
also doing more to help the ukrainians
defend themselves that's what we're
doing we're helping a free people to
defend themselves and so
the uk having been in the lead in giving
anti-tank weaponry is now uh giving six
thousand uh more missiles in uh in
addition to a lot of other support but
there are now dozens of nations that are
supporting the ukrainians and we're
moving really from a a program of uh
supporting resistance to supporting
ukrainian defense of their own country
um could you give a few more specifics
about what success today would look at
would look like uh is it going to
involve more nato troops to eastern
european countries tougher cyber
security measures equipment for nuclear
chemical biological war targeting
putin's guild reserve what does that
mean what does any of that mean in
practice
already putin is seeing that his
ambition which was to try to
intimidate nato is producing the the
opposite effect and he's getting uh more
nato on his eastern frontiers uh rather
than uh on his western front is more
more nato on our eastern frontiers as it
were rather than less and that the uk is
doubling down in estonia we're putting a
detachment of planes in the sky above uh
romania uh we're uh increasing our
support for for poland uh for all the
baltic states and we will continue uh to
do that yes of course that nato's
working together on on cyber uh trying
to combat uh russian disinformation uh
but what the the whole
of the
west wants to do what what countries
around the world want to do is work
together to make clear to putin that
this type of aggression will not go
unpunished what's basically changed
since nato last met uh
more than a month ago is
we can see that the ukrainians love and
believe in their country so much that
they are willing to fight and fight
street by street to protect their
country we've got to rise to the
challenge that that presents to us we've
got to give the ukrainians the support
the help uh the protection they need
you spoke to president
yesterday how is he what did he tell you
how does he seem to be to you and what
does he want you to get out of world
leaders
vladimir zelinski has proved to be one
of the most extraordinary war leaders of
of recent times and i think that he has
marshalled
world opinion and mobilized his his
country and uh what he wants from us is
uh more uh diplomatic pressure
around the world he wants he wants
tighter economic sanctions on the putin
regime and he wants some very specific
military uh support defensive military
support for the ukrainian uh armed
forces and and that we're determined to
provide
domestically prime minister yesterday's
spring statement it does precious little
for pensioners for the unemployed
low-earning part-time workers um some
1.3 million people will be pushed into
absolute poverty next year do you accept
you're going to have to do more in the
coming months what the
the spring statement does is the biggest
tax cut for
working people for low paid working
people in 25 years helping people with
the cost of living during the cost of
living crisis by cutting their taxes are
70 of people will benefit from a tax cut
as a result of what rishi uh did
yesterday we're also stepping up to help
people with the cost of of fuel uh the
9.1 billion we're putting into to help
to cut
fuel bills helping pensioners by keeping
the the triple lock uh making sure that
we keep their uh they're all the
allowances that they they receive but
above all this is the most important
thing and making sure we have a strong
economy uh with
very high employment people in
high wage high skill jobs that's the the
way forward the uk has been it's been
very striking the way the uk has come
out of kobe bouncing forward uh with
with very low rates of of unemployment
and uh 600 000
more people on the payroll than there
were before the pandemic began that's
absolutely fundamental for tackling uh
the cost of living
it will continue to be as rishi has said
because of the global pressures on
inflation uh driven partly by uh supply
strain supply chain constraints partly
quite considerably now by putin's war in
in ukraine it will be uh continue to be
tough it will continue to be choppy but
we will get through it and we will look
after people throughout
finally prime minister russia has put in
a bid to host the 2028 euros
don't you think the host should be
ukraine
look i think that
the idea of russia holding any kind of
football tournament or any kind of
cultural event
right now is is beyond satire i can't
believe that anybody would seriously uh
consider their suggestion and yes i
think that the best thing possible would
be for the entire russian armed forces
to retire forthwith from ukraine and
hand the tournament to them of course